everyone's been asking us to do a
documentary review after the last one we
did on the Michael Jackson one on
Netflix on the Madeleine McCann
disappearance no human read that's on
Netflix now this is I think it's fair to
say the biggest sort of missing child
case in the history of the world like in
terms of money attention media interest
everything it is the biggest part Jesus
and Herod I'd say it's definitely up
there it's a very sad story and what
happened is absolutely tragic and what
we're going to do is sort of cover the
documentary cover the points made and
also in the end try and say what we
think might have happened you know
because it is it's for me this is a lot
harder than the Michael Jackson one a
lot a lot of people say Oh where's the
evidence for the Michael Jackson one and
you know obviously there isn't a smoking
gun no or a pair of pants with Michael
Jackson semen on because it happened 20
years ago and if you watch a documentary
yes and to get rid of all their pants
but there's a lot of people who came out
and accused Michael Jackson there's a
lot of him going if he loved me share my
bed there's a lot of evidence in my
opinion in that sense whereas with this
one it's a lot more vague because simply
a child went missing in the night and
she was never seen again and there
wasn't any prior evidence of the parents
being necessarily guilty of anything
wrong and also there was not nobody
caught or suspected of doing it really
not with any serious evidence exactly so
this is a lot harder in terms of us
kneeling down what we think happened and
I don't think anyone particularly
watched the last podcast thinking what I
want to hear I'm now gonna completely
change my life based on what they've
said but I do think it's interesting
just to explore it because actually one
thing that's similar about both these
documentaries is exploring the nature of
information in the 20th century and then
the 21st century and how we are in a
time now where facts and truth and
surety of things is probably at one of
its lowest ever in history yeah well it
trial by [__] public opinion is
becoming more common isn't it which is a
big theme in the documentary so
they obviously episode one lays it all
out alright so if people don't know
obviously there will be probably someone
who doesn't what happened was a family
went on holiday a delusion porch
Portugal they took their three kids and
every night they would go for dinner and
they would leave the kids for about four
or five hours in the hotel room
apparently they were check on them and
there's a lot of discrepancies over how
often they check on them but they would
check on them and at some point the
daughter who was three at the time
Madeleine went missing and yeah on the
night of the dad had checked on the
daughter he had confirmed that she was
still in the hotel room and in bed at
the time he went back another person and
apparently took a head in the door and
so well actually no so he didn't stick
his head in the door that was he that's
the interesting side of it his side of
the story so it was one of the friends
of the eight I think we're in the Gruber
went away I think when the other dads
went back to the room saw the door was
slightly open heard movement in the room
and assumes just a child turning over
they'll be fine
close the door to walk back out so he
didn't Lee he didn't want to wake them
up I'm assuming so it like that he
didn't have visual on visual
confirmation so later in the night the
mother goes to check the mother sees
that the twins are still there who were
the youngest ones a boy and a girl I
think but the daughter is gone she comes
back to the party dinner party screaming
she's been taken she's been taken now
for me that was a little bit of a red
flag for me that was odd how me because
I know I grew up on in a state where
kids would just go missing in terms of
they'd wander off from their parents in
terms that they'd be playing how the the
parents would come out after a few hours
I mean even young young kids you know I
mean and especially at three years old
kids are inquisitive so if they are can
somehow reach the door handle and get
out which apparently the patio door was
unlocked or whatever and they could
somehow find a way of getting out they
would wander off and go and find another
kid to play with
wander off and go and try and look for
their parents of me
we get lost there's a lot of
possibilities in that scenario the
bottom that the first thing that would
come to my mind if I was in her shoes
she's gone where is she
I wouldn't instantly go taken and not
coming back sort of thing that would be
the first thing I guess the others the
opposite arguments that would be it's
nighttime kids are scared of nighttime
because I think all humans are in some
way scared of the dark because it's gone
three-year-olds aren't assumed I don't
think three are also necessary to see
him but I think it's important for us to
play devil's advocate as we can on this
but three-year-olds are not the same
no but they you know kids have can be
scared of a knight or whatever then
there's also the fact that the window
was open allegedly we'd know was open
and the shutters were up in the window
and that was something that she said was
different because obviously at nighttime
you close I don't know I just I just
found it implausible it was like for her
to nail it straight away
this child is taken she's not lost she's
not wandered off there is no way we're
going to get her back right it it was
interesting that she knit knit called it
so quickly now don't get me wrong I
don't think that that proves anything
but I just thought it was worth me to
metal no and the reason why is because
another documentary I watched called the
staircase which we've talked about
before there's a clip of that on TG to
the other channel he rung the police
when he found her at the bottom of the
stairs and instantly he laid out the
story from day one and there was a woman
who deconstructed his first police call
on YouTube and she said because of the
way he presented the story oh and laid
out and then stuck to that story from
day from the second he called it him to
the very end there was holes in what he
was saying and there was flaws in and I
I thought back straightaway to him going
she's fallen she's at the bottom of the
stairs she's fallen because there wasn't
a guarantee that she'd fallen there
wasn't she could have been beaten up
anything could have happened but he set
his story out straight away and muddled
and Mekons mother equally set her story
out straight away and stalked her at the
entire time I always believed that the
staircase killer
for me he did murderer so that just give
me a bit of a oh yeah well this reminds
me of that no it doesn't mean that this
is the same but I do think it's
important to say she called it from the
get-go that this was what it was yeah
although you can say the opposite of
that which is um she she might have just
been variant and mother's intuition I
could have been that yeah as a parent as
well if if you haven't done something
and your child's gone sometimes your
mind will skip to the worst thing that
could have happened and the worst thing
that could happen is be she's been taken
now the first problem with what had
happened for a lot of people yeah was
what the [__] are two parents on holiday
doing leaving three young children under
the age of three alone with a patio door
and locked which it was roadside hotel
was very accessible why are you leaving
them alone for multiple hours every
single night
it's just careless and really negligent
on their part so there was do you wanna
do you honestly think that do you think
there are other parents out there that
wouldn't leave children in a room if
they if they especially considering the
proximity that they were in allegedly
with him because that's also been raised
as a question yeah I don't think it's
acceptable no I don't interesting I
don't know see I think there's probably
an age where you get to where you could
leave teenagers in a room I think what
you're like I don't know yeah I mean
obviously teenagers but when you get
into about tenure and Riaan under three
and under is definitely so there's the
thing about being on holiday plenty of
times where you see parents who've got
strollers with the kids in there asleep
you can still have dinner you can still
do what you want to do like to me it's
extremely lazy parenting just being like
we need our a long time like you know
that the safety of your kids has got to
be the first priority always not only
that but in the resort there was a
babysitting service and these people
were hardly wanting for it's not a
budget holiday these people know they're
very not another thing that this is not
one of the main reasons people think
that they've been given a lot of
leniency and a lot of a ten
from the media's both doctors middle dr.
Klass got money and can certainly afford
to have someone look after their kids in
my team so it was just it just stunk as
a parent as a parenting levels it was
Pula so isn't that the case for a lot of
people though when they go away or when
they're in unusual situations things
change a little bit and maybe within the
safety of a holiday the romance of a
holiday people think well what's what's
the worst that could happen we're in a
an allegedly safe country which is the
first world or whatever you wanna call
developed nation you know we're in a
lovely resort kids aren't supposed to
got taken on holiday yes of it yeah a
book for me when you're away from home
and in a place you know less well than
your own home you you should be more
heightened awareness not less so I take
your point but I don't think that's an
excuse enough so they raise the alarm
yeah and the police come everyone's out
searching instantly this is panic
station straightaway because she said
she's been taken one of the main
problems was the crime scene or the
where the band was taken was
contaminated by so many people it was
piss-poor from everyone involved
including the parents the yeah I lead in
Kate and Gerry
well I if they are completely innocent
aiyyo aiyyo I do forgive them of that
because the panic that that would set in
to parents I don't think you're thinking
crime see and preserve you're not
thinking you're thinking where the [__]
is my kid and you're worried I accept
that from them I accept that I guess
there are other things that you would or
wouldn't do then in that situation where
they did unusual things like allegedly
close the shutters or move the shutters
things like that you wouldn't put those
back down you'd move those things
windows moved you know I think things
move that maybe you normally wouldn't
move in that situation especially not if
you're looking for a child if you're
looking for a child you would leave the
route that they went out open so it
could come back the same way all those
kind of things those are things which
for me flagged those major a suspicious
strange behavior
everyone's out to check and eventually
they decide you've got to talk to the
media so they come up and give a
statement to heighten away in ass get
that get out there please bring her back
if you have her ie I've got to be honest
to me and there is no normal behavior
there is no such thing as normal
behavior when your child has been taken
it's very hot analyze their behavior and
say that is this but it did seem strange
it did honestly it seemed he they are
such cold people they are the coldest
people I've ever seen in this scenario
and I don't think that if they are
innocent but that has helped them he's a
surgeon she's the I mean their bedside
manner can't be [__] great
no notoriously both in quite not cold
professions but professions where you
need to be and probably sue the person
matter of fact some of these a little
bit more resistant maybe but to me
people who get in that kind of job
they're that help people and I don't
know if body body language wise but they
come out the stairs and they come down
and see it now she's got her head
hanging down yeah and and and she isn't
making any eye contact then and he has
very prepared and and very like I don't
know to me if your daughter is missing
to read from a script and in such a
surgical way that he did it didn't
appeal of the emotions at all in it and
and I don't know you have to appeal to
the emotions do you think do you think
someone who's cold enough to take a
child do oh so things is gonna go I've
upset those people that's terrible well
I don't know what advice they were given
yeah but in everything I've ever watched
in regards to this it's about making the
person who's taken the child see them as
a real person for you and partly in the
language he used he tried to do that he
had seemed but I kept think my whole
time I'm thinking all right judge this
both ways if they're innocent why are
they doing that if they're not innocent
why are they doing that and with her
head hanging down in in I felt like in
shame I felt like she looked ashamed
well I actually thought and and him sort
of we've got to do this if you view it
as they're guilty it that was to
behavior that I was picking up of him
keeping it together okay he puts his arm
round and he's I've got to get this
[__] message out she hung her head in
in shame in my ball if they're innocent
you can view the behavior differently
and think maybe they're just trying to
get through this and they're not good
speakers and they're just trying to get
it out you could also be ashamed as a
parent of the way that you've parented
your kids I've left them alone and
they've got missins another reason to be
ashamed maybe maybe it just out of all
of the appeals I've ever seen there was
one appeal that was quite clinical which
was the salm appeal where the dad came
under scrutiny yeah I thought the dad
had done it because he was very smart or
AFAA yeah I'm so that proves that an
innocent person who's appealing for his
child can't be like that's not isolating
so it isn't a one-off however it was
just odd it was just an odd odd thing
because to me if you're if you're
missing your child you're almost
screaming in agony and terror and the
emotion is gushing out it's some there
was such little emotion I was really
surprised by that see I feel the other
way where I feel like I understand why
people want that but that's part of the
problem for me in the media in the way
that things are portrayed you can see it
both ways so some people want it to be
gushing out but some people would then
go she's too hysterical she's to these
people clearly did it they were gay so
you could go either way with this
information if they if she'd have been
there sobbing you could say she was
sobbing I've killed she was sobbing
however they would have been portrayed
or portrayed themselves could have been
portrayed as wrong at some point well an
image are jumping ahead you know in all
of the the interviews and all of the
statements and everything since that day
mm-hmm I've never seen a single
interview from these two people where
I've seen a real show of emotion I've
and I actually caught a one time I I
feel like I caught a one time and I
don't think once again this doesn't
prove any real guilt no faith crying
100% I I seen a deer
in some sort of thank-you to the
Portuguese public yeah and I was like
and she was making the crying noise I'm
like no you're not you're not actually
crying here and that little things like
that they do disturb me when when we've
got such confusion over what happened
and it could have been them the little
things I thought why would you do that
why not that but needs me down that road
that's interesting because I the whole
conclusion that I was left with from
watching the documentary was monkey-see
monkey-do what do you mean by that well
yeah break that down in two different
ways I don't want to drop to the end of
the no no I'm not but it's it's that's
of a basis for watching it sets up a
basis for how I'm gonna like a lens for
hunger to look at everything okay these
people in a human way are in uncharted
territory as to how you act what you do
what you say a because there's never
been this kind of media scrutiny on that
sort of thing in Britain or in Europe in
that sense and they're also an uncharted
territory emotionally and personally
because they've never had this happen
before and very few people have had this
happen before so they don't it's very
difficult to know how to act and people
learn how to act you learn that when you
go to a funeral you are sad in this way
you know you're not sobbing but you're
very solemn you learn that when you go
to a birthday party you're supposed to
be happy and these are all learned
actions which are slightly informed by
what you naturally would feel anyway the
other way is I think that there's a
there's a balance there I agree but I
also think then the other let the other
way is the way that we then interpret
that from the way that we've been taught
to interpret actions in life so for
example if they've had an upbringing
where both of them come from parents who
are also very clinical they'll not
naturally be emotion exactly she strikes
me and I've you've probably met people
like Jerry and and Kate and I feel like
especially in Liverpool I've met people
exactly like Kate people who you sort of
go okay you have emotion but I don't
quite know where or how to place it I've
met a woman like you before I really
didn't like her yeah I didn't like her
but that and I think that that's part of
the problem I think that what what is
harmed
in this whole situation is that they
don't come across as likable and then
and and they're not I don't think
they're likable and I think that that
has been one of the reasons why they
look more guilty in many people's eyes
they just don't sit and Jerry in
particular comes across as a right dick
it's really there's times where he I've
seen him interviewed and he doesn't he's
a controlling man and and I and I picked
that up from him because when people try
and ask him things you don't want to be
asked or suggest things to him and this
isn't even did you murder your daughter
type questions this is just random
questions yeah he likes to control the
conversation and whatnot and so but
speaking of Jerry you know in these
scenarios the last person to officially
say the child and confirm that they've
seen the child percentage-wise
they're usually the killer and I'm not
I'm not saying that that means he's the
killer at all I'm saying usually now
what interested me was he was the last
person to officially see the child but
nobody else confirmed that the child was
alive after that no one there's no proof
that he's seen the child when he
actually did see the child to my
knowledge and I kept thinking to myself
what if the baby had died I was and
hours and hours before that and they
just because there the time was there
the time was they today and this is
playing the if scenario for them to say
to each other because there's a there's
a there was things found like a syringe
found and it is very common for parents
to give their kids Kulp all in order to
and as they court help them sleep yeah
now if you're wanting peace and quiet
and you're what in your four or five
hour social time every single night when
you're on holiday and you're a doctor
and you think you know what you're doing
you know there was a theory put forward
that they would have potentially
overdosed the child given them too much
can I just check what is I don't because
they don't actually say in the
documentary what an overdose of Cal Poly
would be I've gotten I've got no idea
but this was a theory put forward and
add regardless of how the child might
have died regardless let's just say
someone could have been in a fit of rage
the baby could have been misbehaving
someone gets hit someone bumps their
head on the floor anything can happen
but the time for them to get rid of this
baby and then pretend that they'd seen
the baby later on in the day and
everything was fine the time was there
yeah and the opportunity was there and
and for Jerry to say he's seen her last
proves nothing
so yeah you we have to come at this from
like a real what could have happened
point of view I'm not saying that this
is what happened but the opportunity was
definitely [__] there and the other
side is and something that's mentioned
in later episode the babies who were
still had the twins slept through all of
it that was one of the reasons why Carl
Pohl was suggested because if something
had occurred that was as traumatic as a
baby being tick and a child of three
being taken which would have you would
think would have made noise at some
point or something would have been yeah
commotion would have happened now
something that I think is really key to
it I mean before don't get me wrong a
person could have snuck in and taken
them without the kids noticing but you
do think it's more likely that it would
have noticed something than not the
other side and something's right so that
would be very it's one thing I was
struck with in the documentary which I
understand because you can't go down
every Avenue was there could be a
cocktail of these things coming together
where the parents had given them Cal pol
the babies were fast asleep and
therefore she couldn't scream or she
couldn't do who's asleep
another question sorry to take word on a
different word but if you are as is put
across as one of the theories a
pedophile ring or a child snatcher yeah
why would you leave the other two kids
why would you only take a sir
I guess the the conclusion will be sort
of cargo I guess like you can't take
carrying three kids is very high-risk
one child low-risk I mean potentially
yeah but just I don't know that that
sort of [__] the theory up a little bit
for me because I think that myself if
there was talk of men around the hotel
and
like in the days before looking at the
hotel what whatever was said I mean
there's literally no proof of this but
it could have been the case and if you
were scoping the place out and you had
your eye
I don't know it just seems like there's
three young kids there and if that is
what you do and you have a van waiting
outside in all of this the way they were
sort of describing it could have
happened why leave the other two with
all the other like yeah I don't know
thinking from that position you think
you know and you watch a bank robbery in
a film you always think don't get too
greedy and for someone who's in that
line of work you'd imagine that is a
very easy bank to rob and you go take
one child and that's all they need yeah
mitten maybe yes and we're trying to
understand the logic of really so that
is gonna be a difficult I just do think
that that almost it's a minus on the
credibility of the story and not a huge
- a tiny one but but I just think if
this is what you keep doing you knew
that this was going to be then the
opportunity was going to be there and
you're a well-oiled machine and this is
what you guys do you've got you're gonna
Rob the entire Bank the next thing that
massively came into question for me was
police competence Oh terrible those guys
being that helps the Macan saw you to
think matter sure massively because I
liked the the bald police guy the guy
with just the glasses the guy released
the book in the end I
I quite I liked him as a he came across
as a very you know likable character he
doesn't come across as a great police
officer no so that's the difference good
for a plate you shouldn't you almost
shouldn't like to only lock the time I
thought this case or thought so yeah you
almost shouldn't like a police officer
because they are meant to be quite
competent people they're meant to be
there to challenge you they're meant to
be there to be that figure they're not
meant to be of your friend sort of speak
absolutely not their job and what
continually got Colin the question for
me was every aspect of the investigation
like there's no part of the
investigation where I think you've
covered that off you've done absolutely
every Avenue Jerry and Kate were it were
like they say prime suspects or should
have been treated as prime suspects even
behind closed doors you have to go to
them go by the way your prime suspect in
this
you can privately be looking
two things asking the right questions
building a case of whether they did or
not because when the Americans are then
questioned they always say was a high
possibility this could be the parents or
at least the parents involved in some
way it stinks of a this not really being
a common thing that happened to these
police B Portuguese people not being at
the Portuguese police in the Portuguese
authorities not really having much
experience in this field and I almost
give them a little bit of leniency for
the fact that you know it's a little
village type cop operation here where
they say and what they used to know they
[__] it well and truly and and I think
we would have a we would all I think we
would know what happened if this had
happened in England 100% I think we
would have found that out because
evidence etc would have been properly
checked that's also though why this is
so key is because you'll pick a
vulnerable place you pick a place it's
easy to slip away into the night
Portugal is attached to Spain massive
and then you're on mainland Europe
basically whereas with Britain you've
got to get you know you've got to get
away somehow
you're a mainland Europe in Spain and
all those but you can jump through the
country boys Morocco is arguably a very
easy place to go to after you've gone
through there but the police competency
was a real problem from the very early
time and from from the second that they
were involved I think there are massive
questions of everything they did
questioning the McCanns correctly even
taking evidence things were done weeks
after they were supposed to initially
have been done on the day also I think
there's an if the Mekons are innocent
especially yeah that must be quite
heartbreaking to know you could have had
your child back if the proper things
have been done in time because time is
everything in these things and then
there comes for me the elements of
professional pride where they let their
image and their pride get in the way of
reaching out to other authorities being
threatened by the English coming in and
I get why being threatened by other
people being brought into the operation
because and the only time it's gonna
happen to you in your life is if you
don't if you aren't very good at working
out what your own deficiencies are
accepting them and then accept
help and that struck me looking at the
investigation as these people knew other
deficiencies were they knew where they'd
messed up and they knew that they
weren't as good as either other people
who are coming in and that would be
revealed because these other people
going where's this evidence where's this
where's this
why aren't you checking mobile phone
records like project Omega was or
whatever it was hoping it was set up in
the project range when it was set up in
the UK why were all these things
overlooked and then you think the other
side of the policing competency C really
underfunded C really poorly trained and
like you say a small village operation
where it's tends to be on day to day my
dogs gone missing or you know there's a
copper tree or whatever so you feel the
other way for them or I also feel a bit
sorry for them where they've been given
such a big task in a big burden yeah
you've nailed that there when it did
come down to some of the evidence in the
room the window there was only her
handprint on the inside of the window
and not right and then what they said
when they dusted for prints not even
glove prints see you go you wouldn't get
a fingerprint but you get gloves and if
you think about it there was no there
was no real evidence that anyone had
been in her hands so when they got do
checking the timelines of the people who
are at dinner with them yeah it was all
out of whack and that wasn't a good sign
now don't get me wrong it can be quite
hard to remember what happens but you're
only having to remember four hours five
hours like that that was disappointing
more than anything from an evidence dump
I guess also were they a little squiffy
mmm where they I mean you know you're
going on holiday you're drinking
Portuguese wine you know it's strong
hungry oh yeah you've had a nice dinner
there's a bit of tap ass do that so
didn't they refuse to take part in the
reenactment with the police I think yes
that was literal ATAR again so the
timelines that is what I'm saying about
his I'm saying about police competency
because everything was done so much
later
there have been this relationship
building up over time of them trusting
less and less in the police the more
that more experts from the outside by
giving them advice the more they were
thinking well these police have [__]
up here and then there was the
resentment building between the two
parties of well you're not competent
so you
hiddenness on me because you know
something else has happened and the
relationship between the Mekons and the
police brought down massively from very
early on though I mean there are
different interviews and there's one
interview I know you want a reference
where she basically said no comment
and it caused them a tosser or whatever
yeah that's much later on but even early
on there were small comments from her
where it felt like she didn't trust them
and was maybe being obstructive and at
that point you'd say that's
counterintuitive to what they were
trying to achieve the more this goes on
the worse it looks for me like the my
watch the worse I feel Awards the
ma-kun's and I I do i I kind of want
them to be innocent because you don't
want to think that the parents would
ever do that but they've put a wedge
there quite early on between them and
the police stuff
yeah and and then then I know the police
didn't help themselves either so they
did it was like a snowball effect you
know what I mean
and it's also it comes back to that
basic human psychology of when sometimes
I know it feels weird but you know when
you meet someone you don't like them in
the first place sometimes that can just
snowball and it it feels like there was
that kind of a relationship there
between them where there was initial
mistrust which then became massive
mistrust and then it basically broke
down completely so that the months sort
of go by then really it didn't we don't
really get anywhere attempt on the
documentary at this point decides to
just tell you for 20 minutes about
Portugal which was baffled me I remember
Lucy I quite enjoyed that bit I [__]
hated it tell me I'm here to know about
the Mekons losing their daughter not to
find out what the Algarve's like and
I'll be honest it did make me want to
get [__] annoyed me I'm like is this
a [__] advert I wanted to go to the
Algarve after this I think I've actually
been to the Algarve as a child is what
worries me even more yeah I will I clean
one of those and I don't wanna make too
many jokes about the next thing that for
me was key in the documentary by the way
one thing I will one day all says I did
like the amount they fact they counted
the days that well it helped to put a
timeline in and but seeing that 60 days
I thought wow that's a lot yeah they had
that so they brought in I think that Rob
Murat at this point who was the
translator
for him we weird little translate like I
know I liked it he was just he was just
a guy who lived nearby your first
feeling at him I never thought he was
guilty no thought he was an odd man
weirdo and I also felt sorry for him
because he had all of the he all had all
of the like the trappings and all of the
signals of just being one of life's
normal people
he had a blind eye basically the logic
if you haven't seen it was dodgy I dodgy
guy right like because he desirable he
looked a bit dodgy in some people's eyes
they were like yeah mustard on it but
and and then they basically a couple of
journals met him and they were like he's
got that Ian Hundley vibe and it's like
he he basically tried the thing is in in
tragic circumstances and I think there's
a little bit of this in the sky I've
been in tragic circumstances before and
some reason there's people who are drawn
to that oh yeah they get a little bit of
a buzz off of feeling like yeah they're
in the know and be there helping and
they get off on that and I think he's
one of he's a bit of a [__] and sick
[__] for that he spoke Portuguese II
spoken but he was like translate let's
worm my way into the [__] I'm loving it
I'll finally cuz you know you got
remember this guy lives quite a boring
life for him he's he's live like he's
enjoying it in some ways yeah he's the
keeper of pride to live yeah he's the
guy who listen everything's good he's
like he like that yeah thing is he's
para he really paid the price for
sticking his nose in there and you have
you feel sorry for him as well I do but
I can giggle a little bit because he got
paid out of it yeah his house got raided
three times three separate time like
literally what were you expecting the
fine eat shot but that's again police if
I'm taking us [__] God not for
muddled and do the rain do the right the
right the first time if you great once
you don't go do you check the oven we
didn't check [__] oven we've got to
do another raid but if I go to my doctor
and they check my prostate and they give
me a clearance
yeah I don't need his finger up my ass
another two times sometimes and that is
basically what happened to this poor
bust and it would be terrible I have to
say I think he would bloody love a
finger up his ass
no
right we also be unusual if when your
doctor did give you that prostate exam
it was him let's check for Madeleine
that would be like wait what Oh doctor
so I did feel sorry for him and not not
least because of the treatment from the
press and I I think the press was short
it just be horrible people that's the
next element where the documentary
showed it very well well what was
reported personal motives of everyone
who got involved in your story yeah the
woman who was interviewed who said he
had the Huntly vibe i instantly disliked
because she clearly was loving being in
front of the camera and the woman who
identified him as the one she was going
i am i know about this sort of thing and
he has Ian Huntley virus and you're like
can you [__] how many entities be
knocking around how many people of you
legit she never interviewed Ian honey
she never knew that [__] she just wants
to be the person who went got him and
she wanted to be the one who possibly
broke the big case well this is the one
thing I will cut them some slack on
right I think saying he's like you know
here's Joe however serial killers
murderers often get off on being in
front of camera and dangling what
they've done Araya or seeing the
reaction of what they have done actually
if you're in sera around people and so
for example in the making a murderer
sting the woman who died ex-boyfriend
was around a lot in that time and people
say that he was probably the one who did
it for example I'm just saying and and
maybe she put two and two together and
got five because he was around a lot so
I get I kind of get why they thought he
should have been questioned but he got
way worse that's a ever deserve the
other side of that is if you're a good
and this is again where I think the
documentary finishes quite strong
is saying how poorly the journalist did
not help actually dude they were put in
the headlight they had a picture of this
poor guy he'd oh you know or they found
porn on his computer like oh did Lauda
bollocks yeah absolute bollocks and they
paid well technically the journalists
did not pay the price for that he got
six hundred grand for a
normally you get 300 grand I think he
deserved like I think yeah I think
million if you wrongly accuse someone of
doing that [__]
you deserve million also because I think
because his name was so tarnished then
they and he says this at the end of the
documentary never got to a point where
they found the killer
they found it a real in other words away
it means also that he's gonna have a
problem getting rid of his property I do
think it's weird that he stuck around in
that place if I'd had such a and I'm God
forbid that I would ever have that kind
of experience but if someone's had such
a terrible experience like that do you
really want to then stick around in the
place where you'd have it you've
certainly experienced struggle too but
um no I
yeah he got royally [__] and then
there was his website designer who you
know what well he would got I can't
remember this one right
it was a long documentary this [__] so
probably about four episodes too long
I come what Rob Moretz business was born
he did a website made and he went to a
Russian designer in prior deluge and the
Russian guide had to leave Russia young
he had to leave Russia young because of
his parents having financial
difficulties so he said he'd always
wanted to make something of himself in
Praia deluge and he was a web designer
so he worked with a lot of people and I
think you sort of techie guy in general
stretch of his very techie guy they took
his computer's because they thought that
Rob had been in cahoots with him and
they've been working together now I'm
the computers that they took the rumor
is that they found a lot of child
pornography he then claims that that's
and they're not his computers they're
clients computers and in the documentary
he really struck me he refused to answer
what was on the computers oh I remember
that right yeah that's a very awkward
hanging moment because you don't hear
very often the voice of the people
making he does say he dismisses it and
goes look any computer that you've got
you're gonna have porn on there but then
but then clarify that you need to then
say love you if you'd be looking at big
booty [__] what's your problem I just
say that yeah you'd only avoid that
question if there's something wrong
wouldn't you yeah I get that there are
some
those were very prior proud people and
he's probably been put through the mill
no this was that was worried that is
that way that's weird and then there was
the other factor of his late-night call
from I think from Rob Mara to him around
the time of the train which made me
think what we were you really why would
you call him the Oilers web designer
you're calling him 11 o'clock at night
what the service down what and neither
of them remember the call even Rob Murat
was out yeah of caught remember that I
might not have it but dialed him via a
pocket dial the Sameer
yeah which the thing is once again
that's weird but it's nowhere near as
weird as some of the stuff with the
Mekons so it's kind of like which road
do you go to but it is a bit weird so
then comes my favorite part of the
documentary the sweetest dogs in the
world finding either what I like no he
wasn't no it was it not the Mekons a
second interview with the police first
okay yeah it was well yeah okay so let's
go down look at cannons so the Mekons go
for this second lot of questioning and
the first lot of questioning it will be
in brief as [__] anyway no what were you
having for dinner yeah what what was
your favorite a pass it was it was very
um yeah so Madeleine McCann
disappearance the fort this is in the
independent it's all official xlviii
questions cape makan refused to answer
in re-emerge now to me at this point she
probably surmised that the the police
were potentially looking at her as the
murderer or whatever
now just because that might be the case
does not give you the right to ignore
all the questions if I've been in a
situation before as I said people know
by now I've found someone dead before
now when you find that person dead the
police have to go through a certain line
of questioning just you almost cross you
off the list that you weren't involved
in this in any way it's the practice now
I didn't I didn't take that personally I
thought you're doing your job I
appreciate because if something hard
have happened that was sinister I'd want
you to ask these questions your
so I'm not hanging over you especially
that yeah and when you love or care
about the person who has gone missing or
died in anywhere you want to do
everything you can
yeah to help yeah so when I was getting
questions not quite like this because
this is a different but I've been
questioned on the something might have
happened where you might have been
involved before I answer every single
question in as much detail as you give
me everything because you think yourself
you're helping this man do his job and
you're also removing any doubt that you
had anything to do with it and it's just
common sense you know what I mean yeah I
feel like I've been here before so if I
had to say what well anyway well I'll
read the question yeah I think you know
the funny thing is we've actually done
this exact interview before on this
pocket okay I'm gonna be reading this I
was the mayor the third this is 2007
around ten o'clock when he went of the
apartment what did you see what did you
do where did you look what did you touch
not know no answer did you search inside
the master bedroom wardrobe Shawn two
photographs of her bedroom wardrobe can
you describe its contents
why was the curtain by the sofa near the
side window tampered with did someone go
behind the sofa how long did you search
the apartment how long did your search
of the apartment take after the detected
Madeline's disappearance why did you say
Madeline had been abducted
I don't know bright assuming Madeline
was abducted why did you leave the twins
to go to us to raise the alarm
the supportive doctor could still be in
the apartment or around why didn't you
ask the twins what happened to their
sister or why didn't you ask them later
on they were fast asleep in from Cal
Poly well we don't I you know but the
point is by the way one more moment yeah
when you raise the alarm at Thomas what
exactly did you see
what were your exact words yeah and
there's just you know constant there's
an what in total 48 quest questions that
she refused to answer right now that all
right you might be offended that people
think that you might have had something
to do with this but
come on take your ass out you're a
doctor you're a grown woman you know how
the world works you've got to clear
yourself and do the right thing answer
these questions I am I refuse to accept
if I'm a police officer here that is a
good enough excuse for you to tell us
that all [__] yourselves when we're
trying to find your daughter
now this grace that I'm not even I'm not
saying that this means she's guilty but
it doesn't look good
the other side of it is then when they
when the English people got involved
when all these people got involved she
was very open and honest with all those
people so it does it like that says
earlier with the relationship between
people and that's another side but what
book I don't know like I get what you're
saying that's not good enough from her
as a mother your child's gone missing
everyone's out searching and you're
refusing to answer questions
the the the logic I guess they're for
her and I'm trying to get into what that
would be would be you are trying to pin
this on me so any information I'll give
you you're gonna try and work it back to
make me look bad I said nothing wrong
Zack Lee yeah then you've got nothing to
hide the same way when I phoned my
friend dead I had nothing to hide so
therefore I answered every [__]
question with nor fear with nothing to
hide yeah there was not an ounce of me
that thought and even when our he's on
why now I think even for maybe a
millisecond when I'm answering these
questions the thought crosses my head ov
over hope they don't think I've done
anything yeah do you know what you think
well after summer because I know I've
done nothing yeah and I care about this
person too much to hide away and not
answer these questions so the other side
is as well and I think some adds to the
interview process for me which i think
is awkward the language barrier so
there's a massive language barrier
between the police and they're a
probably prime suspects and be the
people they should be helping so either
way having a translator there is not
gonna make it easy and that's where I
don't think that the British were
involved quick enough they should have
been there next day in the same way very
much the journalists were and that was
really troubling for me next on the
timeline comes to of the sweetest dogs
you've ever met in your life
- under that you love the dog I love the
dogs and I think the dogs first of all
explain why they were there then the
dogs were just two dogs knocking around
randomly and they went lady in the Trump
we can help what I've got a bit of
information you want might warm yeah I
can slip things out so they met them in
the bar no so there's a guy then a
specialist who's bought him he's trained
his dogs in in a way where he can saw
these dogs can pick out specific things
only those there's there's many
different dogs that they've got so
there's one dog that they would use for
weed one dog for cancer apparently
ghastly herbs and obviously there was
two dogs that they used one for blood
and one for rotting corpse liquid a ver
great abra-cadaver and the side of that
is that dogs can't be swayed in a case
they're not emotional about this they're
purely being rewarded for when they find
and to a point where I believe it was
trained to the point where it could pick
out which finger that it was on or
something like that no not even the hand
like the exact point not only that but
there was something so the FBI tested
these links and there were 12 cloths one
had human blood on it they washed it
three times then the dogs are sniffing
again still found the one with the blood
on it very accurate very very good so
these dogs are going around the flat now
there is another side to this which
people say well you could he could have
rewarded the dogs that could be a signal
to the dog going back over there or
whatever but I think I'd be very
difficult it's on camera and you watch
it it's very convincing that the dogs
are sniffing sniffing sniffing stop and
they're bought by either bark or point
because one of them was very sweet he'd
point with his nose in very nice so that
for me is very sweet I love it was these
dogs are diligent do you know they've
got they've got little personalities and
they're going around the room and
suddenly they'll stop and you'll either
see blood or the body and that was
really troubling for me because I
thought well you know the Wardrobe and
the curtain those would seem like two
places you put a dead body at some point
if you if you were trying to hide it or
something like that
and what the dog's got no other motive
well doc it's a treat however it finds
something or not so people go well it is
because it's motivated I know the dogs
get fed the same way either post
ordering so it still knows either way at
the end of this exercise I'm gonna get
something they're timeline-wise
this is where it gets a bit tricky
because they hired a hire car after the
notification that she'd gone missin 25
days they say on iPod I'll go back to
the [__] typical one of us okay we
can't not make the least one Joe
throughout this part yes because this is
who we are so we're not being constable
the we're making a joke about me using
the word notification yeah so the dog
had picked up the scent of rotting
corpse in the hire car and and that was
tested as well so that the problem is
obviously it by that point the child had
already gone missing why on earth are we
picking up rotting corpse in the hire
car and there was other things that it
was picked up on so we've got the curdle
cut the teddy bear that was seen under
Madelyn McCann's mother's arm when she
came to report the missing child how on
earth would there be rotting corpse on
Moodle car when if she'd gone missing
why the mother's clothes that would
there be not the mother's clothes the
baby's clothes the hire car unless the
report of the child missing and then got
rid of the body
later other people also say well it
could be the rotting flesh of a chicken
or whatever that they've cooked the dogs
specifically can find the difference but
don't get me wrong I think while I
believe the dog that's not that's not a
certain size ever thought I'd [__]
believe interviewing Snoop Dogg so I
while I believe and I I personally take
it as a 95 percent accuracy in my head
there is that percentage of there might
be something wrong this is an animal
yada-yada-yada
so it's it's just it doesn't look good
once again it's just another thing that
looks bad it looks terrible for me it
should have happened much earlier
because if you do that early on and
you've got access to
garyun Kate McCann early on before the
trust is broken down and you going in
you go neutral
animals have found this you are then
putting pressure on people because it
could it could be also that they that
they were abducted and for instance the
person had to slowly escape from the
flat so that originally they were on
their way out Jerry came back the person
goes into the master bedroom and had to
hide in there or they hid behind the
sewing that could have happened accrued
the other side of it that wouldn't make
sense is if the body had been hid in the
behind the sofa or something that
happened behind sofa and then it had
been hidden or something had happened in
the master bedroom there's no way that
they can get the body out of there after
they've reported it no I I think for
sure the if the parents had anything to
do with the death they'd found a way and
these are not people who would one of
the means of money they've got money to
take the body away put the body
somewhere come back to the house tell
everyone yeah I've just put the kids to
bed go to dinner and then agree between
the two of them you're gonna say she's
gone missing she's been taken later on
and with how clinical and how cold of
people they are I believe that they
could have done that I I'm not saying
that that's what happened but I think
they've got that within their
personalities to execute with precision
these are not dumb people these are not
people without money these are people
who are switched on and not the most
emotional people you've ever seen and
these are people with more kids to twins
to live for - and in their heads we've
got to make sure that we avoid prison
because we've got two kids to look after
things like that you can rationalize it
you can you and I I've been amazed in my
life I've known some really shitty
people in my life who have done some
horrible things to people and it amazes
me what people can get themselves off
with like alleviate guilt and just be
like oh you know this happened it's not
our fault we've and I do but I can
especially Jerry he's the strong one
he's really don't like he's the strong
one he's the one who keeps the other go
we've got to do this we've got to get
through this
whenever anyone attacks them he's the
one who's so
right after the blood was found because
of the dogs they basically were able to
find blood that we were able to test for
DNA before the DNA tests were given
Jerry and Kate were being interviewed
and one of the questions was how did you
feel when the blood was found yeah an
incident because Jerry's always missed
that in control regardless of whether he
did or not but especially if he did it
if he thought I've got a lid on this now
we were out we're in the clear now when
this happens it's a first time we've
ever seen him shaken yeah he rips the
microphone off now I'm not doing this
now and it's the first time I'm like in
my head I thought or you're rocked you
up you're worrying you're worrying or
what this Bloods gonna show here and
that possibly more than anything else
because to me I think remember my friend
died I found my friend and and for a
minute they I was in a situation where I
was being questioned about what had
happened if if if any evidence had been
found for example that it
alluded to the fact that something had
gone wrong knowing I was innocent I
would be happy hmm I'd be like great the
found blood
maybe she's clawed the guy maybe it's
his blood I'd be delighted
I wouldn't be ripping my [__]
microphone off and panicking and Sean I
was visibly shaken and not for me when I
was looking at I was like oh this does
not look once again there's no proof of
what happened their body language their
answers their non answers is showing
didn't build its signs of guilt to me
and I and I might have this completely
wrong and our an apologize if I do
because it's a to accuse parents of
killing their own kid is a horrible
thing but but they're not helping
themselves as what I'm saying you you
help yourself when you just you show
signs of innocence and when someone
finds blood in your apartment you should
be happy you shouldn't be shown that
you're you're shook doesn't look good
although you know then you can say the
other side of that is that was in a
media interview they don't a lot of
media stuff you know they've had a lot
of questioning over that there they're
sick of information being leaked by the
police so they were made official
suspects right after this I believe and
another another thing that doesn't look
good in my opinion is when you're made a
suspect hopping on a plane and going
back
England like why would you want to
because they can clearly a forward to
stay there it seemed that people were
coming forward to helping their with
money and it's like we're getting on a
[__] plane here and we're going now
and to me that was another sign of like
terrible PR in a first place if not
terrible guilt I think it was just guilt
to me they were like we're worried now
we're scared it's turning the tide is
turning so this this is and I toured not
to get carried away because I am quite
annoyed by this whole thing because the
idea that someone would kill their own
kid [__] pisses me off but once again
I have to try and remove emotion from it
maybe they just didn't trust a
Portuguese put police exactly maybe that
was the case however if you're really
wanting to find your child being in the
place she was abducted seems like a
better course of action than [__] off
back to England and when you [__] off
but England as soon as people start
pointing the finger at you or it just
doesn't look good once again so to
counter all of what you said they're a
they if you believe your child's been
abducted you probably believe your child
is as far away from prior deluge as you
could be when you go back to England
because there's no way that the child's
gonna be possibly within the immediate
vicinity at that point they've got can I
just yeah there is a case in America
where a kid was kept about seventy eight
miles away for sixteen years but that
just happens sometimes absolutely
understand that the other side of that
which would then play into is look we've
had no joy so far we're never going to
be able to go into the basement I think
it was a basement that child was kept in
for so many years we're never gonna be
able to go into the basements of all
these people in this area we can't do
any more searching we can't do anything
else and the other side of it was that
the UK government I think at that point
had sort of got involved and I don't
think they were particularly helpful in
the sense that as soon as that UK got
involved the Sun the all the red top's
basically got involved and started to
make it a nationalist thing where it was
like the competent British police should
be taking care of this not the
incompetent drunk idiot you know foreign
as when you say that so for example if
if
that was their attitude of which it was
we we can't know but if the Mekons
attitude was we can't really do anything
more now yeah
why go on a some sort of world tour
because that was strange to me
yeah can we talk about the the water
what do you one thing they went on some
sort of broad show yeah well that's what
was called and that's how it was
portrayed it was weird hi I mean I kind
of once again I I guess doing something
is better than doing nothing or you know
you're trying to search for your
daughter you're coming to the conclusion
she's probably not still in Portugal but
that perfectly intertwined with the
Portuguese police deciding they might
have had something to do with it say
we're going on a sorry well just saw
we're just gonna go and check out the
other countries now where she might be
yes fair enough she might have been that
but just two quints you know y'all
saying are we caught which is probably a
million miles away now we can't really
do anything and then they go on this
tour I don't know it just
I think we're does the word II so him in
my head the other way side of it for me
was the the religious side of this whole
thing where so religion is a lovely
thing for a lot of people I felt when
watching them and maybe I'm just cynical
because I'm other words a lot of
church-going wasn't there's a little
Church going by these people she left a
lot of answer machine messages and stuff
in the church there was also a lot of
church-going Durham pride allusion by
the way raid the church yep like I'm not
saying nothing I'm not saying it's I'm
not saying it raised the church I'm not
saying it is a like a prime suspect
place but if if a child's been taken a
church will have no problem with you
going in there and just looking around
right side note I think we know what
you're getting that I mean let's be
honest if we're gonna go off track
record the churches should be the first
place the police make on it so kids got
missing right we're going to church
after the church why just just please
yes um don't worry the the priest only
ever really portrayed one side a priest
is a very good public relations outside
the church and she goes I just wanna
[__] you all
the hospitality you know and she fake
cries I looked at I was like she's
[__] face they then go back they hide
it for me they use faith to hide behind
and I there's nothing I hate more than
people who use their faith to hide
behind well so the people who were of
her church were portrayed almost like
family members yeah and to me this
documentary really didn't explore the
possibility or the probability that the
Mekons could have had anything to do
with this it was all every person they
asked like apart from the one Portuguese
police officer every person the police
officers buckhorn
the churchgoers all their friends were
like nought couldn't had anything to do
with it and I was like I think I would
have preferred it if the documentary
maybe had have explored that possibility
more I get what you mean there are a few
things I wish it had explored more like
a course their friends are gonna say it
now it was nothing to do with them
awesome okay so the opposite of that is
they can't
the documentary obviously can't go
guilty because legally then just can't
go out so they have to leave it to you
to make the conclusion no but I don't
think it just give other people's points
of view like well they wouldn't do this
and the way I felt the opposite way
where I felt like it left a few things
hanging where I thought all right
they're trying to tell me there that
that's in question or they're trying to
tell me there that for instance some
people who analyze their actions some
people analyze them no but it added in a
lot of things to give the possibility
that something else happened to her a
lot more than it did with the payer and
saw it for example like the the
pedophiles in the area like don't get me
wrong that is an important point there
is but when the copper copper goes-p
doors need holidays too I was like is
this really am I really hearing this
right now also the that pedophile said
the specific pfr they talked about the
one who's targeting the kids go through
medical mask he targeted English
children I think he talks to slightly
older children but still targeting glish
killed Rijn it was in the 40 mile radius
or these kind of things that will borrow
me the other side to it is
I thought they look guilty win them at
the Pope
all the parents yeah really yeah made
you think that just the way I don't know
where maybe you be like oh my god it's
the Pope's or actually I was like yeah
there's one rule of thinking where some
people say to me would they really have
gone on that whole sort of crusade to
find their child back if they were
killed in yeah I'm like yeah yes yeah
with it you when you meet that bond if
you if you do that you you they're very
smart people and they're smart enough to
say to each other we're gonna have to
appear like for deciding this can I have
to commit a hundred percent yes we're
gonna have to meet the Pope we're gonna
have to but I think that there would be
moments where you say that in the
planning stages whatever though you're
gonna have to if you're gonna remain
free people you're gonna have to
[__] to the nth degree
double down and and that means if you
meet the Pope but there would be moments
there will be moments where not in their
words but their body language and if if
if you're like did imagine you'd kill
this kid you're like [__] how where
happen to meet the [__] Pope to do to
get away whether she's religious the
allegedly rehearsed people that and even
if you give us shame will seep from
their [__] paws
so that's what I thought was a real good
clip I thought was a real problem for me
was when I met them I thought if I was
religious how would I feel if I met the
Pope I wouldn't I wouldn't do it that
way put it that way if I what did i do
or was it okay great image and she was
showing you always draw her she she
whenever it's a high-pressure situation
she implored I the first video when they
first come out so coffee help don't
think had don't you know I'm saying like
I have a feeling that you think this
this is that one went one way
no I actually the thing is though and I
don't know why I don't know why but I do
feel a bit sorry for Kate more than
Jerry and I think it might just because
I think Jerry's an [__] I don't know
but what okay thing about her way
because she implodes because she if if
they're guilty once again there's no way
it known but because she implodes and I
can say she isn't as strong as him
and she's not as cold as him and she
feels more and maybe sorrow for the
child
the loss of life maybe that's all it is
I think it hurts her more it's harder
for her get through situations more
whereas he is more selfish men usually
are anyway and more ruthless and more
able to get through these situations and
because she shows more weakness
I feel sorrier for her for her when
parents lose children is very common for
them to split up yeah and because
they've stuck together this whole
[__] time I can't help but feel that
there is something keeping them together
as well yeah and and and I don't know
like I just feel like he is in those
situations where she's having to do
ridiculous things like meet the Pope if
she is guilty of it he is sort of
drugging her through it and you see him
cuddling her all the time um rounder
come on yeah this trade either way he
might just be that kind of husband he
might be like oh maybe he's just a
supportive guy maybe I don't know what
I'm talking about what I don't know like
I can we talk so I had a question which
I was sort of if we sort of explored
this situation enough here have we gone
through the actually looking at it now
with their back to England and they
never went back to Portugal until the
police officer wrote a book about them
accusing them of being involved in what
we our opinions of him writing a book
multiple opinions to be honest so that
okay so there's a few things on the one
hand he was getting called everything
under the Sun and he kind and he kind of
deserved to have a say back why she did
a podcast or summat yeah but he thought
he did the same and he had to have his
say and I do think he was entitled to
deny the claims about himself in a book
however the book or in an in one article
in a national newspaper a [__] book
mmm
a book maybe as to but the end of the
day the national newspapers who have
already destroyed him have probably sold
a lot of papers based on that themselves
have made a lot of money for themselves
so money is going to go wherever his
opinion goes regardless yeah so there's
I don't
I thought the book thing was tacky but
you know he deserved the Hubble you see
he looks better now he's definitely used
the money well to slick he's done the
Georgia Marine your thing he's got he's
quit the job and he looks ten ten times
better yeah no more doughnuts ironically
all those claims that use a fatty me it
seemed to have worked yeah
bullying does one YouTube comments a
testament of that with me but anyway get
up whaling I do think he probably
overstepped them well he definitely
overstepped the mark and some of the
things he said in the book from
Washington and but for me the most
interesting thing was the Mekons
reaction it's like oh now you want to go
back to Portugal huh
nah no you do want to go back to
Portugal until it's time to make sure
that you're in the [__] clear i I
don't know I just thought like should
you not have been back on the
anniversaries and things like that and
maintained a relationship with the poet
and try amend look cuz to me right I
know they didn't like the police but in
my head I'm like your daughter's missing
you don't like these people but these
people might be the only way you're ever
going to get your [__] child back so
you better make sure you've got how many
people do we work with on a day to day
basis should we think of [__]
arseholes but we just get on with it
because we need them to achieve a goal
imagine your goal is to get your
daughter back you make friends with
people if you [__] have to the other
side of that is the UK and those people
were informing them basically these are
incompetent and you shouldn't trust them
fair enough
but they made no effort at all they
could have at least tried to mend fences
a little bit okay so only climb they
turn off is to get in the court and to
make sure that nobody believes that they
did anything that's like Jeremy
newsflash
half the [__] will think she did it
pallets me wake up speaking of and for
that reason they didn't take part in
this documentary by the way they didn't
take part in the documentary despite it
being on arguably one of the biggest
platforms in the world one of the best
chances for them to raise awareness for
their daughter's disappearance
on top of the 11 million pounds they
didn't want to take part it because it
would enhance the conspiracy theories
and it's like literally me and you are
involved you're gonna have a much better
say you're gonna be able to put your
site across I don't know like he's his
actions are just very strange I know
they don't line up with an innocent man
that
the parents's auctions some of them line
up with Anissa people but too many of
them for me
lineup of people who are riddled with
guilt I say they should have sent a card
now but anyway they should have sent a
card to the police first of all sorry
mate
secondly the bit which really I found
bizarre in the document while we still
on the cop I think we probably have it
recovered yeah we covered the police so
basically we think he shouldn't have
written the book I think was
unprofessional tucky is also
unprofessional
a policeman the whole point of your
position in society is you're meant to
be able to handle secrets you meant to
be able to keep these and let's not
forget and and I hope that we haven't
tread this situation with a lack of
respect a girl is missing and he is now
benefiting from the fact that a girl is
missing now I know your your job as a
police officer is to right wrongs and
new crime is your business but not in
that way it's not and if you bust a drug
dealers then fair enough but this is a
little baby girl well some people would
argue justice is much bigger and it's
sort of Arc's much bigger than him so if
it goes for if you trying to just
justice in a small case you'll actually
make the arc bigger because it takes a
longer to for justice to be should just
be I don't know he should have just been
running a little restaurant somewhere he
wasn't and you know what I bet he would
love running a lovely restaurant all I'm
saying is I felt like it disrupts
justice and it disrupts those things
better than it helps those who helps
himself more when it happens then when
you're and to be speak on the half of
the makan side when you're confiding and
you're going through a situation like
this with a police officer you don't
want to be worrying about the fact that
he might write a book on what you told
him one do although he also he clearly
has gamed the system and I think it does
show the justice system in some
countries probably every country is
insufficient they kept all the
information to themselves because they
were talking about the privacy that the
police have in Portugal but they were
but they were leaking things to the
press so yeah I think the Daily Mirror
got a copy of her it was Daily Mail
something got a copy of her private
diary yeah the only source that could
have been from was the police and and I
felt sorry for her once
and when that happened because you know
if she is innocent
she's obviously writing some of the
worst feelings that she's ever kind of
experience as a parent in there and that
is very private
and that that was when I really felt
sorry for her that was if I was like a
little bit rocking the other way then I
was oh god that [__] I feel really bad
for other also though she's never gonna
write in it yes I did eight like that
that would be crazy I think although I
would if the police are watching I would
inspect that see there's any chord in
there yes the first letter of every set
in the stocks with I the I D I T you
know love him yeah but she didn't put
any spaces between I so cards these
people getting a lot of fan mail and
hate mail yeah well yeah did you find it
first of all the reading of one of the
hate mails I found very bizarre Jerry
was very cold very he almost looked
callous to what was being said it was
sort of like I hope you are curse your
family the rest of your lives you're
using innocent people's money to solve
and pay your mortgage what the thing is
right there's it's one thing having that
opinion
what kind of [__] the right side
look at Christmas card that you then
that's basically tricking someone into
definitely reading it I obviously am
leaning one way I think that's quite
clear right now but there's no proof of
it yeah so and because of that you know
I wouldn't sit either of these two
people down and accuse them of things
because I really do feel like you need
more evidence to do that but to then go
through Google find their address out
and write this [__] postcard what
kind of psychopath would do that well to
put it on top of that
what kind of nutters then sort those
into different categories of the kind of
cards that they received I'm lucky a
Christmas I don't even give a [__] about
cards from my local don't write me a
card but these people are getting cards
year round
hope everything's okay hope is all good
you think that's lovely I put that in a
nice I'll keep that imagine you did it
and you're getting people well wishing
you as well you're like and I couldn't
another one like I genuinely like being
nasty is someone in the past like or
whatever
I got quite guilty over like I should
never have said that yeah I really
shouldn't have said that the times I
mean you fall now and I ring you like
the I'm sorry for in the dick yeah I
can't imagine the level of guilt like to
get through that in a life would be and
not not know there's just small tells
though so I feel like those are the
small town so if you keep and catalogue
the terrible cards that you are
receiving there's something though you
think are these people cataloging this
for a reason is that a tell if we are
bad people we need to keep these bad
messages we are or I didn't see a part
which I could though which was like you
know hate mail
don't catalogue it just put it in a bag
it's not something you need to get was
just in the kitchen on the side like
these are all weird things that's that
is so weird I thought that's really
strange I understand if you keep one and
you go this would be something and it
was the way he wrote it yeah immediate
fashion I think he giggled a bit after
he liked it and I'm like can we just
your daughter's missing yeah she's been
missing for a long time people think you
did it they're sending you hate mail
because they think you did it and you're
laughing about it coming the one when I
say it like that it's weird yeah again
really weird not only that you've
catalogued it kept it and it is in piles
okay is weird that's just strange it is
bizarre people who are separated from
the situation like live and yes house
that's too big no no pay for by the
public of course separate separated by
the situation is important what did you
think of all the people that surround
the McCanns because it's in this point
in the documentary where you see they
employ a PR guy who puts them on a bit
of a PR offensive well he does it was
awful
by the way he well they've got 11
million pounds to plough anew this
investigation again ourselves and
and the sort of father for though all
that they've had a few bad fan mail the
goodness of the public came out and
supported them including billionaires
and whatever milli hundred million is
and who put their own money forward by
the way the so that that's I get on in
just a second so the PR guy is awful
he's probably one of the worst PR guys
I've ever seen so he advises them badly
and then gives an interview on TV where
they say you understand that Jerry and
Kate
they don't look remorseful they don't
look sad they don't look as if you know
they're still grieving I if I was the PR
guy my reply would be Jerry and Kate
have grieved privately in this situation
and really want you to respect the
distance between the them and you know
the situation his reply well no one
could say how much you've got to grieve
he said no one needs no one can tell you
how much you have to grieve no don't say
that
because that he no longer grievance of
what that implied was that they had you
know a couple of weeks and they were
like yeah well I feel a little bit
better that was an awful couple of weeks
[__] doubt was the worst holiday ever
you know I'm just like I remember I mean
this is the thing people think me and
Lawrence are different it is weird how
similarly we think right I remember
watching that and being like what the
[__] did you just say son what did you
just say so so then he just she doesn't
follow that up by going sorry what
she's guys yeah absolutely no then that
was actually a really good no because
when I think when you're an interviewer
thought when someone's coming up with a
[__] like that yeah you like don't check
out yeah he thinks he's on a roll here
he's gonna give you more [__] like
Jerry and Kate at the psycho don't worry
guys this is why you pay me the big
what's this I'll show you how it's done
Jerry Inc no deny that they killed her I
mean at this point is up in the air she
like me
ask me no questions I'll tell you no
lies as their PR guy very well that's
why also then the flip side of that is
that there were they begin they began to
be surrounded by people who were Robert
Murat well-wishes but on a sinister
level where they knew for instance one
of the guys said this is great for my
exposure so this is really good exposure
for me so people use them as a way and
probably a tax offset as well to be
honest we like just throw a lot of money
at the situation you mean and then okay
so now let's talk about the millionaire
who sat on the couch that was way too
big for him his sofa
you know the millionaire his sofa is
[__] he looks like he's taking the
cushions out you know when it like a
toddler would take her up the cushions
off but how small does he look on that
sofa what a weird man so he was a
multi-millionaire who had been buying
the world's biggest coach this man of
the world's biggest couch but he made a
lot of money I think from double-glazing
and a few businesses why why give these
people millions when you know that there
are so many credible sources out there
there are so many worthy cause yeah I
think why I give money with with the
Mekons being shrouded in did they or
didn't their to pick those people to
give your extra millions to and not for
example children's charity which is in
Italy early all good and you know once
again the Mekons might be innocent but
the fact that they might not be is
enough for me to go well that's
definitely not innocent about a charity
yeah general so that that was a bit
strange that did strike me as unusual
and then there were a few people as well
who said well when I met them I knew
instantly that they were innocent to
those people I say it [__] really
[__] because you never met them so
how do you know it's not there was times
where I warmed to them a little bit and
this times and ultimately I want them to
be innocent so I'm going to
truly in that way despite all of the
strange things that they did in the
aftermath but there is not a single
person on this planet other than those
two people who know for a fact if
they're innocent
so I can't sit here and say definitely
guilty or I knew I knew you don't anyone
who's sitting there at home right now
there's not one of us who can sit in so
I know this unless you're Kate and Joey
we just can't do that so people are
talking [__] when they say that okay
then it sort of troubled me then after
that it brings it on for pedophile
Richardson yeah sorry just to those
people I found an interesting way the
people in Portugal were praying the
people in their local church were
praying and often okay rather than be
there and be thankful or injury rather
than be there and say thank you send a
little message Cheers you know that's
strange as well because to me if I was
in that situation and there was an
outpouring of emotion and I don't know
two hours and things like that before
try razor and nip down the street and go
at your church if they're all praying
for you you know be then I know that
they might say oh the cameras would turn
up or whatever I don't know I just found
it if there's an outpouring of emotion
be there with those people it's also the
reliving of a tragedy going you've
already maybe in your grieving process
you've already been through that well
that's a good boy
it's a good point and maybe that's the
truth and maybe they just wanted to sort
of let the days go over and not have to
deal with it but I don't know that was a
little bit maybe I'm being harsh there
before I think you're probably right if
that's the thing it's all dependent on
if they're guilty so if they are guilty
and also I'm comparing their actions to
what my actions would be and that again
isn't fair because everyone acts
differently but but that's what the
newspapers preyed on the newspapers
praising everyday people and I think
Kelvin Mackenzie the piece of [__] says
it during the documentary when he says
well we weren't thinking about facts we
were thinking about the emotion of the
headline and the way that you feel when
you see it and even says it in the
Leveson inquiry which was partly not
ball around
that bought around by multiple things
madam was one of them and he says yeah
we we go on if we if it looked right we
generally thought it was right and you
thought use piece of [__] German you
know to even call yourself a journalist
after you've said that it makes you the
biggest piece of [__] I've ever seen and
Cal McKenzie we know as a history anyway
lying in public but it or miss
misrepresenting truths he and every
newspaper and a lot of our outlets
benefited from this happening because
they were getting through housewives who
thought god what if I left lost mine
there would be two fathers who thought I
find it they played on people's emotions
to sell newspapers and the British
public were right for it that time and
it was a this was pre like the prime of
the Internet
well yeah and also it was in an era
where obviously we'd see in the so and
murder as murders happen and kids had
been I don't know it felt like a new era
where you had to be more worried about
kids going missing and stuff like that
that's what they prey on fear that's the
next question I was going to ask you do
you think the McCanns if they did it or
whoever did this crime get away with
this crime today if it is done today
because I thought that very little until
later in documentary chat about tweets
Facebook those things I think one that
actually says Facebook was only a year
in Twitter was in its infancy mobile
phones were different then as well so
they didn't have the good cameras now if
someone saw something happening people
tend to whip a phone out and go all
video that or I'll take picture of that
just in case it's in my thought yeah
things like for criminals it's hot it's
getting harder and harder sure that you
get away with things I don't think
necessarily it's about when it happened
as much as where it happened I think if
it happened now in Portugal probably
still get away with it but do you think
though that in that area do you think
though also if if Jerry and Kate are
because I put some serious thought into
how the news cycle works now and how
people go through every aspect of a
story but in different ways
well when when you talk about the media
I think if Jerry and
Kait particularly had have come from a
poor background and were working-class
people and didn't speak the way they
spoke
the media's treatment of them would have
been different and you know they would
have been punished for being like
neglectful as a child they would have
been absolutely drawn through the mud
you know I mean and a lot of people say
and especially if their skin color would
be indifferent if their background had
being different people would have looked
at them an entirely different way they
have been very lucky to face no backlash
other than the public opinion so what I
find interesting is and I do wonder
Twitter and I think Facebook and social
media has changed the way that
consciousness on a public level works
now they brought that up in the doc
where they showed some of the trips are
being written about called some people
trolls which I was uncomfortable with
because actually some people I think
some people probably were trials but
some people also were probably just
saying I think you're [__] done it
you piece of [__] I think the way
they're portrayed in the documentary
which I think the whole document we did
lead towards they are innocent from the
director but to discount people raising
as we're doing right now real questions
even if you believed they were innocent
most people still have questions about
this so the Mekons if they one can be
like oh yeah we've got a few trolls not
you have got a huge percentage if I
would say at least 50 percent of the
population really unsure whether you did
this or not yeah you know so to discount
it as just trolls I thought was being
very kind to them so the other side of
that is then in modern media now it
pretty much goes through a cycle where
you'll see all the bad press and media
come out at once then there'll be a
slight rest a few opinion pieces on the
weekend and the week after you'll see
the other side of the story explored
where they'll go so terrible terrible
terrible good and I wonder if it's if
now the Jerian Kate did it or not if
they did do it whether it would almost
make it easier for them to come out and
admit that they were those people who
did it and because the media will give
them a different trial by media than you
would have gotten back in the day which
would have just backing that back then
was a couple of people who had big
national newspapers and big channels who
could talk now piñon can be swayed by
smaller amounts of people so YouTube for
example like I mean this I think will be
kind the mainstream media don't have the
same poll that they used to they can't
just kill people the way they're used to
because he thinks easier for them to
admit it now so I think now they get a
kinda reception if they were to admit
they'd done something terrible then back
in the day when basically they'd have
been buried yeah I still think they'd be
[__] but I think it would be terrible
for them regardless I don't think that
would change but well what do you think
of the people who say they saw someone
carrying a child and what do you think
of that woman who said she saw two men
by the pool all these people what do you
think about so I like I said I've
experienced like that kind of a little
bit of a situation where I found someone
dead before and a lot of people kind of
just want to come out and have a camera
in front of their face yeah and I've had
I've read reports on situations where
I've been in situations before and what
is written down and what people think
this see and and all of that and it's
very rarely like oh yeah I was driving
and I seen a couple and they look like
they didn't want to be seen and I'm like
yeah I'm watching the documentary like
how did this make it into incredible
supposedly credible document there's no
evidence there's no nothing that this
could be any they could maybe they were
startled because you were driving 70
miles an hour in a 30 you know whatever
you know what I mean like there's not so
to me unless there's anything really
concrete I tend to just sort of blow it
off really so then what do you think
about the pedophile ring side of it
because the harrowing side of the
documentary was where they described the
mother of another child who's poorer
Portuguese went into a went to the
police very little happened very little
money wasn't very little time was
invested very little anything was
invested into it but she found basically
a catalog for pedophiles and young kids
and she was allowed to see it and it had
her son in it and that crap that made me
look I felt sick when I heard
and you think okay then there's that
possibility as well I mean that's that's
the worst of the worst that any parent
could feel and yeah that as sick and as
sad as it is to accept that is a very
real part of life now we're kids
thousands of children go missing every
single year and Madeline Kahn is an
exception to the rule where it was
raised the awareness was raised and
heightened to an unprecedented extent I
do feel like they're connecting things
that may or may not be connected or you
know that once again I think it was an
important point I raised for the
documentary that these things happen and
it could have been this but there are
there are so many other circumstances to
be taken into account as well so it's
important to know and that these things
happen but no fingerprints were found in
that no no handprints were found in that
room no no no evidence whatsoever of a
person coming in there other than the
parents so until I've you know it's
acknowledged but there's nothing to
piece together here so you're looking at
it like very okay well that's what
really first everything comes back with
the Mekons that frustrated me about
documentary because it only dealt with
individual timelines for each person and
it for me it didn't mix the timelines
enough and sort of go so if the McCanns
have gone to a place where they know
that there would be an easy escape for
anyone who wanted to take their child
maybe they've there not solved their
child but they wanted to get rid of her
all these kind of things why didn't they
mix timelines because there's no point
where they assess whether there's
someone who's been in the police there's
no point where they go where the police
are part of this was private I think the
one thing that was an interesting point
was that on the dinner bill I think at
one point there was these this couple
have to have this time slot because they
leave their kids alone
so someone booked a week ahead yeah and
that wasn't allowed for anyone else and
it was said that that was why the kids
were left home alone and I don't know if
that was specifically written but it was
there was a reference
on the on the dinner booking and I was
like that is a bad thing the right
honored dinner but we left in public
site as well yeah one of the guys who
was the private investigator Kevin
halogen just a small detail he he was
found to be a fraud so he was another
one of those people who benefits off the
back of the McCanns and all good sent
someone a threatening I think he the
text message or email with the lyrics
from gangster's paradise have you do you
remember this part I do actually yeah if
you're trying to threaten someone Coolio
if you're gonna try and pick a rapper to
use their lyrics I don't know maybe 50
cent maybe biggie
Coolio would be bottomless living in
gangster's paradise
I think that also gangsta paradise it
sounds like a nice place to go general I
mean do you want to go gangsta's
paradise with me yeah i know i'm a loc'd
out gangsta set trippin banger no you're
not met yeah you are little music sound
so don't arouse my anger eyeball alright
don't be don't be caught and Coolio
maybe he thought he was pretty hard
doing that didn't and when you've seen a
picture of him you also imagine I can't
imagine that man listening to Coolio
death day nothing but a heart beautiful
my conclusion I think most likely
scenario there's no possible 100% this
happened what is the most likely
scenario with everything that we know
can I do you genuinely think that we can
work out do you think with the
information we have we can work out why
it's the most likely scenario mm-hmm I
think so I think Pedro ring is is is a
scenario that could have legitimately
happened I do I do think if they were
prepared to go in there and snatch a kid
they wouldn't have just taken one that's
not that is my opinion but maybe I'm
being stupid there and people can tell
me in the comments of I am but I don't
know I I think that these guys the worst
of the worst and I am the worst case
scenario so maybe I'm wrong but
regardless it is a real scenario that
could have happened
terrible I just think with them Khan's
actions I would lean more towards them
having an involvement in it
and with the dog with their behavior
when the blood turned up and Jerry
clearly rocked by that and worried and
her imploding under the pressure and
fair crying and what do you think of
that the wider bigger conspiracy theory
about it being like that these people
initially had had a child snatched then
it became such a thing basically good
people got involved with terrible people
who were like you know global pedophiles
kind of level and they were don't
understand what you mean there's a big
theory out there I think online that
basically people in the media were
scrambling to cover up what had happened
and so it does not serve them to have
the McCanns founder there's there's been
cover-ups before I mean a lot of people
might have heard of a woman called Jill
Dando
it was a news reporter in the in the
past who was known for uncovering things
and people assume she uncovered a
pedophile ring that has been later
exposed I think that's actually beyond
assumption now I think people yeah I'm
just sort of covering this a bit but
there was obviously a pedo ring in the
political slush entertainment world high
society where very famous people were
Peters and she is alleged to have
stumbled upon that and someone went and
shot her on a doorstep one day and so
these things are [__] real they are
real and it's just sick to accept that
but it is but in in regards to this yeah
the the dogs highlighting the dead body
scent and all of that and the DNA
turning up and I think the match of the
DNA was 15 out of 20 and although that
that is a variable that could be quite
common and it could have been from the
family I don't know that there's a lot
that points to the Mekons in my opinion
and and if I had like sort of bet on it
that was that was where my money would
be interesting I was sort of left the
other not the other way but I was left
much more neutral originally when I
watch the documentary I thought
this is gonna show them as guilty people
it's gonna be very damning especially as
they didn't take part in it that's
another thing that sort of made me feel
a bit strange I felt more neutral by the
end of it and I felt not more confused
but it's just like the same other do the
more you look into the Michael Jackson
thing what you more you look into all
those things there's just a deluge of
information which doesn't tell you
either way it's all just accounts it's
all just people go well what about this
but what about this what about this
there is no there's no one out there who
can tell me a definitive story of what
happened and that really frustrates me
obviously I don't know this I would I
would definitely lean towards the
parents doing it to be honest with you
but especially based on chance and what
they say psychologically all these kind
of things that it needs to be someone
who's close it's very rarely does the
thing yeah here's the thing for me
there's more evidence or there's more
science that point to them than anyone
or that person and that's that's that's
it fingerprints DNA body language
interviews more points to them than any
one other person now that might because
the person who did it has never been
caught and they never left a single
fingerprint and then there's no evidence
that it was anyone else was even in the
[__] room other than them but that's
what I'm left with really and that the
problem with that is now is that I
wouldn't lock them up over it I wouldn't
I wouldn't if this were a trial there's
reasonable doubt there is there is and
I'm not talking about reasonable that
some people mistake it for any doubt and
II don't and reasonable doubt or not the
same thing there is reasonable doubt for
the Mekons and I could I wouldn't be
confident enough to say if I was in a
jury they did it but I'd find them not
guilty and then I'd be that [__] at
the Unruh cause I do think they did it
but there's just not enough [__]
evidence support them down here put it
this way they're unlikely to offend
again and I think I mean I don't mean
that trivially but I mean society is
meant to be protected by prisons and
those sorts of things
these people have done something Passa
potentially terrible if they did it if
not you kind of think the life that they
now lead is probably a big punishment
for it it's a little bit like OJ Simpson
you you you to that but look at Jerry's
when he read that hate mail card oh yeah
he doesn't seem like someone who's
living I mean that's just a tiny window
and maybe at night when you go to sleep
your touch tortured by memories or
whatever I don't know but it's amazing
what people could forgive themselves
with I agree however that's only on a
conscious level and I think
unconsciously if someone's done
something terrible they live without for
the rest of their lives and I don't
think you ever really get over that that
becomes the fabric of a person rather
than I disagree though I just I really
do I thought I I think I think you're
you're talking about me and you you're
talking about regular real people who
who feel pain when they even hurt their
friends feelings in order to and I'm not
just speaking about the Mekons here I've
I've met some people who done some [__]
[__] things and can just wake up like
it's nothing there they're out there the
word sociopath spun around the cycles
people they really exist these people
and they can do whatever it takes to
preserve themselves and not just how
they are I get self-preservation I guess
what I'm saying is no man unconscious of
all these people are tortured in some
way and you can never really wanna be
the kiss you want to feel some justice
there isn't no so ISM it's more than if
it is the case then these people live
the rest their lives the fact that
they've done that and Karma's not always
direct I just think there is always
gonna be some comment like with OJ
Simpson when he had he couldn't go to a
I think almost thing comic and I think
if you do enough [__] things eventually
something [__] will happen to you but
karma as people believe it I don't
believe in karma I think I've known some
of the nicest people I've ever known
have had the shittiest hands in life
some of the offs biggest [__] about
the best Sunday I don't believe in karma
particularly I would love to sit you and
be like yeah well eventually they'll get
they won't they know their family but
that's what I'm saying privately they
were serious ways of working out I think
sometimes it can be a thing but not
every time it doesn't have to be one big
thing you know it could be little things
on a daily basis right you know you
can't make a cup of tea because she had
a cup of tea all those kind of things
and I hope people have I know that this
probably would have triggered it this is
the thing there's a reason why
podcasters youtubers avoid [__] like
this you're gonna piss people off your
it's a serious subject it isn't funny
it isn't light entertainment we make a
choice as podcasters to tackle this type
of [__] and this is because you want
this from us so you know apologies if
we've offended people off we haven't
handled it in in the most respectful way
we do try to do it while keeping it
somewhat entertaining but there's a
reason why everyone else avoids the [__]
so just at least we're [__] trying
you know give her a little bit of leeway
in the comments if you could let us know
because I think there probably will be a
short series of these yeah we love
documentaries so we might as well give
this keep going with some stuff like
this I've also got so much stuff
followed up from Michael Jackson I don't
think we should do one follow up podcast
dedicated to it I think in time give it
a while the truth real world title
because to be and also I'm what isn't
helping Michael Jackson from beyond the
grave is his some of his psycho fans who
really don't like me very much after
yeah I said things I also just think
this embrace week people out there
someone just sent me a clip of him
saying how he's how he who is innocent
you know but if you if you love Michael
Jackson then just be nice to me then cuz
I'm not being nasty to you personally I
just don't like what he might have done
that's true however every person is just
a mixture of mixture of concepts and
actions and things so if you love the
theory of Michael Jackson and the theory
of a person being good and pure and
light then surely you want to explore
whether someone actually did something
terrible because actually you don't love
Michael Jackson you love the idea of
Michael Jackson and that's all but it is
true jody podcast hopefully you've
enjoyed it hit the like button subscribe
if you like if you want some more yeah
only that we more will see you again
next week